until nakisha not a [ __ ] Lacroix the
body sugah feeling with ticket to jail
he we met ELISA who me way to join in
flamenco mafia today on the podcast what
language teaches us about identity can
you be more recent but yet not speak the
recent creole language can you be Latino
but not be fluent in in Spanish can you
be a fan American butts it's not be
fully fluent in so called black English
welcome to choc radio a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare my guest for this episode
created a course that teaches students
about how language helps us see and
better understand our world
Michele de Graaff teaches the course
Creole languages and Caribbean
identities the course highlights how
linguistics can teach us about broader
issues of identity history education and
more throughout this episode will be
intercutting professor degraaf's
answers with his creole translations for
now we'll let him explain more about how
he developed this unique course with
schmancy su developme Avex research is
about trying to understand how languages
evolve over time and what happens when
new languages are created say for
example the Caribbean in magnitude Haiti
where Haitian Creole emerged in the
seventeen eighteenth century so we try
to understand the patterns of
development of the things that we call
Creole languages and in terms of a
structure but also of an applied sight
my work where I try to understand how
best to use say Haitian Creole and other
local languages in education and how
that's crucial for developments of
countries like Haiti so the course
started out of a desire to try to have
increased accessible to a broader range
of students and within which we could
connect languages to a lot of issues of
culture and identity and as I'm from
Haiti and as my research is unclear
languages I try to think of ways in
which we can
use the history of Creole languages 2002
issue is connected to linguistics
identity history sociology education
even though the course focuses on
Caribbean identities and Creole
languages the course requires its
students who come from all over the
world to observe what language means for
their own identities sits in wing a
bolero fit can you be more recent but
yet not speak the recent creole language
can you be latino that might be fluent
in in Spanish can you be an American but
yet not be fully fluent in so called
black English so those were questions
that they themselves brought in
then what I asked him to do as the very
first exercise was to write what I call
the linguistic biography and actually
and I get this hand from a dear friend
and colleague professor and Sarah C
Hadley and charity actually shared with
me her own lingzi biography and when I
read that their eyes how powerful it was
to read about her own growing up in
terms of language ethnicity race so I
thought that I would ask to this or
something similar the connection between
language and power is highlighted in
this course a lot of what comes through
in students language biographies and
other assignments touches on power
structures and the hierarchies that
exist because of cultural misconceptions
tied to language and also race I asked
professor de Graaff if students brought
misconceptions about Creole languages to
the course and how he unpacked them
HSL you come and see quoi as I can see
the vision so one way that we start
unpacking these misconceptions is by
comparing attitudes towards languages
with attitudes towards race and
ethnicity and as they get what we get to
see very quickly is that in fact there
is perhaps as much misconceptions about
language as it is about race so they get
to see very early in the course that
language can be used as a proxy for race
so now it's impolite to say certain
things about say black people or Asian
people yet it's still polite to say
pretty negative things about language
and then and then at that point what we
do want reduce some basic linguistic
analysis tools for them to be able to
see that in terms of musics structure
there is nothing at all that's inferior
about Creole languages in fact what we
do from the very beginning is to show
that structurally they are patterns both
in the syntax or mythology of calamities
that are quite similar to patterns in
the syntax and history of of English or
French of Mandarin Chinese
so the equivocal isn't that empirically
and theoretically one cannot argue that
qo languages are anyway less than non
calamities the same way that there are
no biological measures that would deem
black people to be inferior to white
people so they get very tender Stan the
power of this means that often they
themselves have brought along in terms
of how to view different languages in
some case communities and other kids
just even dialects of English there is
southern English or black English their
attitude that are very demeaning towards
those varieties that have no basis in
science that are rooted in hierarchies
of power and they get to see that very
quickly
this course the covet is discussions and
and in order for the course to be
successful we have to be able to discuss
very delicate personal issues in a very
safe way and to be honest it cannot be
that students are afraid to reveal the
positions and various topics including
race language identity and one way to do
it is to given that I had at the very
beginning of the course I had the
questionnaires about where they came
from I mean which is they spoke where
they grew up I was able to to use that
to trigger discussions you know so if we
really talks about authenticity for
example if an African can you be an
authentic writer if you write in English
example then I knew that some of the
students I dealt with this issue for
example where a student who although she
was black and Hispanic she wasn't very
fluent in Spanish and and she wasn't
clear whether her not being fluent in
Spanish neither any less Hispanic you
see so I was able to use that in order
to trigger a discussion around this
notion of grand red in this famous
debate between Chinua Achebe and googy
what jungle about African writers can I
write to be authentically African if
they write in English or French for that
matter so that that was one way to
trigger rich discussion so the motive
there was rich discussions are best
arrived at if they came from a personal
basis where students are are invested in
trying to find an answer that can work
for them in the in the personal lives or
in the lives of the families the
community is the country is etcetera
another special feature of Professor
degraaf's course on OCW is that his
instructor insights are available in
both English and Haitian Creole I asked
him why it was important that he share
in both languages how the course was
taught for me is to be made for time so
it was very healthy
crucial for me to do this interview in
both English and Creole because I see
Creole languages back even in the case
of Haiti especially because of Haiti as
a
particular revealing and clear test tube
or history to really show how language
can be such a powerful tool either for
lumination or for its instance either
for oppression or for development so I I
would love teachers we look at the
course to see how they can adapt the
content in order to address similar
issues in the own community because I
think that what you see happening in the
case of colleges also happens in in the
u.s. appengine in in Europe in America
in Africa where language is often used
as this technology for domination or
resistance and I think this course gives
the some basic analytical tools to be
able to analyze these patterns and and
for me it's also very important that
teachers in Haiti and soon as in Haiti
including say you know future leaders or
policy makers get to understand the
discourse and the readings and to
understand that that Haiti could do so
much better if teachers students leaders
had this awareness of how the old
attitudes towards Creole versus French
have played over centuries in keeping
the country in the developed and if they
could get a better sense of the
importance of language in education
development then I think the country
would do so much better and for me it's
a it's a key bottleneck that we have to
go pass in order to really be able to
develop a nation is to be is to be able
to and understand the history and the
nature of your national your ancestral
language and to be able to use it in the
most systematic and productive way if
you cannot do that there is no way that
you can develop a whole nation that
speak that language while the students
get to understand at the end of the
course is that we all hold dear certain
attitudes about language and so
everybody choose are positive for us
doesn't for others but oftentimes and
this is actually one of the major issues
that we discuss throughout the course is
that sometimes we have attitudes that
have a negative impact severe negative
impact on the lives of other people the
lives of sometimes entire communities
and nations so I hope throughout that
students can actually take the theory
Dallas's in the
and series in which they can apply it to
themselves to the communities to the
countries so some in the course of this
class I've applied what they've learned
and taken it outside including
volunteering in say the usual English
program that just started in in Boston
is a Jewish program promoting the use of
both in Creole in English and where
students are immersed from kindergarten
in both Korean and English and now
there's a student go to that class
myclass amis volunteering in that
classroom for kindergarteners who are
learning in Creole and in English and to
me that's a person as a dream because
it's one case where what she learned in
the course can be directly applied in in
the real world context where she can
make actual positive change in the lives
of these children
[Music]
professor de Graaff shares additional
thoughts on teaching Creole languages
and Caribbean identities within the
instructor insight section of his OCW
course you can find these dual language
videos along with his openly licensed
teaching materials at ocw.mit.edu and if
you use these materials in your own
teaching we'd love to hear about it use
the contact link in the show notes to
share your story until next time I'm
Sarah Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare
[Music]